and I like that that lyric uh I got I
took some pills she took the dogs all
it's all H that's a hell of a one she's
gone to her mom god dude and I took up
drinking since she took the time to tell
me I took the best years of her life God
sad it is sad man sad s make me happy
yeah I wonder if uh if people relate
more now to sad is do you think the
overall that music's sad or different
than it was when we were like growing up
and you and I are probably more closer
to age in Earnest but like I just wonder
sometimes you know I think so I think is
there more s music real auth more
vulnerability okay there you go it was
so curated so music used to be curated
there was it was the labels were in the
power and they would curate songwriters
they would pick the songs they would
make the artist record the songs this
like it was a big deal when artists got
to start picking their own songs in this
town there was a time where like labels
were like this is your song I called it
I get in trouble every time I do this by
the way but it I called it the
Build-A-Bear system right like Nashville
was like builda bear like they would
find a bear they would put cowboy hat on
bear cowboy boots on bear they would
give bear a song Give bear a guitar make
bear have a band of bears behind bear
put bear on tour put bear on radio and
it was completely like they were these
dudes were like robots they were
Muppets right you know what I mean for
the the system and the power and what
we've seen in light of the internet and
I always compare stuff to like other
things for connectivity and comedy we've
seen it as well right and podcasting and
and the the ability to y'all to go
direct to Consumer right like like the
idea that a guy like Zach Bryan can be
writing songs in the military and sets
up his phone and just sweating just
singing his ass off and can connect with
people with with no in between right and
that's why sometimes the establishment
don't like him because they had
absolutely nothing to do with his
success but we've gotten to a place
where like we're back this the last time
this really happened and somebody's
going to argue with me but them was
in the 60s and the 70s the singer
songwriter movement yeah right where you
would see guys that were like writing
their own songs and singing their own
songs Willie Nelson whan Dylan James
Taylor the The Outlaws but I mean it it
went over like I was playing uh you know
Jackson Free have you wrote with him yet
oh yeah he's a I love that kid I think I
think he's going to be he's 23 in the
next 10 15 years remember we said this
name Theo this kid's going to have 30 40
number one Jackson Free Jackson free
spells it with an X but he didn't
realize how deep Dylan's catalog was
because like if you're like I don't know
if do you ever get into Dylan Bob Dylan
Bob Dylan yeah no so the was it the
nasal thing that threw you off I don't
remember I just don't know if I I I just
don't remember him that good but it's
like you've heard some of his songs
without knowing right heart gold is that
him uh sounds like Tom
P oh yeah
like man I don't know if that did in the
basement mixing up the medicine I'm on
the page about the government yeah I
think wow Bob Dylan was kind of rapping
but he also wrote Along the Watchtower
yes right like he like and Jackson did
realize this and I'm playing them all
these big records I'm like you know 10
Bob Dylan songs I could do it for you
right now where you're like no I don't
I'm like I play them you're like oh
I do know 10 Bob Dylan songs I just know
didn't know Bob Dylan wrote them yeah
because but it was a different era these
guys were like writing their own songs
and singing them and then we went
through the 20 30y year curated space
uhuh and now it's like there's a lot of
guys that are singing their own stories
again and that's why I think the
connectivity is different and I think
the vulnerability shows because it's
just men being honest
in their music so it might seem a little
sadder but I think it's just more more
authentic yeah that's a good that's a
great answer yeah I agree with that for
sure Jesus Christ that's a good answer
thank